hello and welcome to this video i'm
playing
with black against grand master arcanada
50.
that's grandmaster akadi
rochstein that's that's a weird one to
pronounce
whatever i do i'm doing it wrong
i think he's he's a german citizen now
for a very long time
but originally
probably from the ukraine if i'm not
wrong
so rochstein is probably
not totally wrong to pronounce it like
in german fashion
okay so he's playing a king's indian
attack type of
setup um
well what if i just play it like i'm
white yeah
double fiance i was not really paying
that close attention to
to the opening here this one yeah
bishop b7
e4 knight b4 must be fine and if i
manage c5 this is definitely fine
yeah okay so i get in c5 and then
white's
setup looks fairly lame
at least it's not threatening in any way
now this is always good to have him
asking some questions
on the c file so what is he doing after
knight d4
moving the queen again yeah
taking looks uh
uncomfortable
yeah on the other hand what is rook d1
doing not much
rook b1 i mean
so if i play b5 now he's going knight e3
f94 this is just good for black
maybe he wants to go no i thought he
wants to maybe go knight a5
i mean this is just good for black
without any
without any hassle
making his pawn structure
making his pawn structure great again no
we're not going there
um so
bishop d4
is is one thing just protect the pawn by
placing the bishop on d4
it's by the way this is not like losing
for white or anything
it's just uncomfortable he's just stuck
with that weakness
okay i'll go bishop d4
rookie one maybe for a tempo then rook
e4
he's maybe active enough to make this
somewhat reasonable
yeah i just go here and
pressurize the pawn
i guess knight e5 is what he wants to do
but this is a good move anyway so let's
play it
if he goes rook d1 i have c4 that is
important so he's going back
okay queen to b3 it's not a good idea
there's d4
queen to a2 okay you can do that
and try to be annoying
it's an interesting way to play i'm not
sure about it but
it's probably playing rook c1 okay so
let's do something that is useful anyway
and then see how we continue
it would be pretty nice if we can
get to alekhine's gun the rook to d5
yeah that would be
the absolute best way here to
put more pressure on him
i have a weakness on c5 it's just what
it is
must be should be aware of that
a little bit down on time
maybe like maybe queen c2 he could have
played
i mean that was not what i'm playing now
was clearly not
the most ambitious way to play but i was
a little bit irritated by the time
i wanted to be wanted to
simplify it a little bit
and then it's got rook c8 okay
i have three seconds that is the thing
what he's doing here is not anything
good really
just hoping that i'm screwing this up
which is reasonable i have absolutely no
time
so i could screw it up
it would be pretty painful because he
just played played a really terrible
game
but um i didn't really put him away
that's the problem
now that was just awful freaking awful
uh i mean
losing this position is really painful
but i i played it but i pretty played it
badly
i mean this is just a total control
position
and then i i squandered away too much
time by far too much time
trying to um yeah whatever i tried
and then when when i had no time i was
going for this
which is yeah giving away most of my
uh most of my advantage
but this is i mean he's probably
defending this it's kind of awkward but
i mean this is pretty much bettening
down the hatches yeah like
defend all the weaknesses that we
created with white
and here i mean this is of course not
bad for me it's just a bit difficult to
manage
yeah i should probably play queen f6
simply
i mean i can take the pawn of course
it's not
not impossible but
it's it's a little bit awkward actually
i still should not lose but
i was certainly i was frustrated here
that that it came to that because it was
like really odd e5 is rubbish i'm still
okay
because with the queen covering h8 i
cannot be checkmated it's just not
happening
but um yeah after that i have no move
so i mean no move is strong but
not nothing good yeah
i wanted to play e4 and give up that
pawn you're still
probably not losing but clearly that's
not what you want after this uh
totally one-sided game it's just like
this this opening play is really naive
and here white is just in terrible shape
e5 is
maybe even stronger but this is such a
such a one-sided position
rook fd8 is actually already winning
here for black it seems
okay now the engine is going down a
little bit
this is a moot point the the problem is
actually what i did is i was
spending far too much time here because
you're much better with basically
everything
and just play quickly yeah and not
um get into this time pressure at all
the only way to lose that game was
with time because from the purely
structural point of view white is so
hopeless that you
um you have to really kill yourself
which i managed to
manage to do this is important it still
happens to me that i'm
taking too long it's just a joke that
you get into time trouble
really in this position because it's so
one-sided you can play
essentially everything like here yeah it
took 30 seconds for this move
i was thinking this is interesting queen
a2
but you know it's kind of it's really
pointless because you're better with
everything
and then just play a good move quickly
i'm much better with that in in
classical time control
or longer time control there i would
just play a6 probably plus
press the clock but in blitz that
happens to me and this
leads to these completely useless losses
where you kind of just give the game
away i mean if you look at the eval
i'm exactly worse
once in the game here and then i'll then
i
didn't move anymore so that's um
that's very bad pragmatic play you just
have to
be be somewhat fast if you control the
position like that
yeah that's uh really i mean even if i'm
absolutely
i mean that's not really good but even
this is a huge advantage
because when they take yeah i'm just on
those open files and he still has
weaknesses
yeah okay queen e1 somehow c4 is not the
best move
i'm kind of rambling here because i'm
upset yeah because it's
not a game you should ever lose so
anyway thanks for watching